this is a very strong tournament
including a mix of young Thailand as
well as experience what are your
expectations about this tournament
seeing that chess and United States is
thriving there are so many young
intelligent players that is very
exciting yeah in general and
one very exciting thing for me
personally is getting to play against a
lot of guys that I haven't played in my
life yet so this is interesting honestly
I think if I apply my best trust and I
don't get lucky I'm probably not going
to win and if I apply my absolute best
stress and I do get lucky then I
probably will win uh so part of that is
within my control to a degree and part
of it is not so just focus on like
control play the best stress you can and
hope for the best uh well when it first
started playing I was in FM so I didn't
have much expectations my goal was to
play as well as I could and then try to
improve that on the next year
but as I've gotten stronger um you know
the tournament's gotten stronger as well
you know my only goal is to make sure
that I'm I can just play the way I'm
capable of playing at my best and uh you
know of course give it my maximum effort
for every game and uh and see what
happens
I think as long as I can play my my best
chess and show what I'm capable of
winning the tournaments not out of the
realm possibility
um for me it was just a unique challenge
that you know once it got the invite I
was like I have to play the US
Championship you know even even missing
like three weeks of school it's gonna be
it's gonna be tough but you know I I
just made other arrangements in yeah I
think it's something that I would do you
know no matter what I didn't I don't
really have that many expectations but I
want to play fun chess I don't want to
get boring games hopefully
my opponents don't listen to this
interview because maybe now they're
gonna try to make it like super boring
it's so nice that uh you get a chance to
face guys like Fabiano Lavon Wesley
Lanier all these great players
um I think that's made a tremendous
impact in
getting that experience to play these
world-class guys uh as for what I expect
I I'm just trying to play good chess
here I think
whatever result comes I'm I'll be fine
with it I just want to play well I mean
I'm still having nightmares over my loss
of Heroes just from a month ago but uh
yeah certainly it's fun and exciting
also this year we have more players more
rounds so it's going to be a long-end
challenging tournament so it's going to
be interesting now that the tournament's
getting stronger and
try to win more titles is going to be
more challenging but but it's fun
because you get to play against top
players also up and coming players such
as Crystal Fairview and I wonder
yeah it's it's a challenge so obviously
getting super strong not only we we got
one more
um super DM like Levon but also the the
younger players
um they they seem to to be getting
stronger which is normal and and then
the combination of the the super DMS
with the with the younger players who
are obviously improving and getting
stronger and stronger makes it for I
think uh really great field of players
and but I liked it I mean I like to to
play Such tournaments and
look forward to to the challenge well I
would say that for the past
since 2014 and 2015.
like the two main goals that I had in
chess that were unfulfilled where I went
to cross 2700 and win at least one U.S
Championship so I still haven't done
either of those although I'm close to
2700 now and I've been close in a couple
of championships had some chances so
yeah obviously I do really want to win
this tournament one day hopefully it's
this year I mean that that's my goal but
um yeah I know it's it's going to be
very difficult I I hope that I can fight
for the first place last year I I fought
for first place I didn't make it and I
misery at Levon is a new addition to the
tournament and to U.S chassis and and
all the usual usual guys you know Wesley
is the defending champ so I guess he's
the man to beat this year but we also
have a lot of newcomers or guys that you
don't normally see in the US
Championship so that would also be
interesting